would you overlook cheating
from time to time
just a side check no i would you would
you'd overlook it i wouldn't you
wouldn't even if also your bills are
taken care of completely till you die i
wouldn't you wouldn't okay
i wouldn't um if i had kids it might be
different but if i didn't
yeah if i didn't have kids
um and i was still i felt like
if i was still like maybe my age now
mm-hmm
yeah
i wouldn't overlook it because a trait
that i look for is loyalty
and
for me i understand that the male nature
is to spread his seed you know go find
out what like what he wants
and
yeah so i i can understand that but i
also think that
them given into that nature of you know
like even if it didn't mean anything it
was just like a one night stand you know
he was just caught up in the moment
that to me would
be like you're you're a weak man you
can't hold like especially if we had
something really good going on
and we had a really good relationship
we've been together a really long time
and
and then you just [ __ ] up one night
like that to me is disrespectful to me
and then i wouldn't go back with you
because
now you would probably do that again
because i've accepted that that's how
you are now you [ __ ] up from time to
time can i just ask have you been in
that position before
no i've never been done
but you know what you know of i was just
gonna say
so for you why did you say yes
i don't believe that men
can not cheat okay and when i say men i
mean most men
i think i think i think they're just
built to
i think
you're dating the twenty percent you
mean we're not designers
with one person don't say we're not
designed to cheat because that's because
you're assuming that the woman is
like somehow like deserving of just me
alone no no no what makes you think
she's she saying on desire to be
monogamous but no no that's not her
words let her say what she's saying she
said yeah they guys let her talk she
said cheat guys let her talk go ahead go
ahead hello
yeah i don't i don't i don't believe
that men
can just be with one person
is that from experience you've been like
cheated on a lot i've in fact i've been
cheated on but i've never found out
until when i was it was way way away
something he's never affected me but
i kind of feel like
it's a
scientific or genetic whatever you want
to what however you want to put it i i
feel like men they they think with their
penises and
i wouldn't i personally if i was with
someone for many many years and then i
found out that they cheated on me i
wouldn't throw away a whole
that you know that whole sort of
relationship for for one person
who was probably insignificant i
wouldn't i wouldn't because she did
that's that that was the difference or
she did say
if it was a side chick like having a
relationship on the side you'd still be
speaking to them
oh sorry if it wasn't a one-night stand
if it was a one-night stand
or
a
relationship over a period of time is
that both acceptable
yeah
okay and would you think if
if he does cheat on you would you think
that he still loves you yeah i would i
don't i don't think i don't i don't
think a man cheating means he doesn't
love his his partner agreed because i
think i think not to be controversial
but monogamy is a social construct yeah
which isn't bad it's i know you know it
it works for our society and it's very
natural if without a society societal
conscious or social construct we will do
what we want we do as we please we
brought right back down to our biology
exactly the twenty percent will get the
eighty percent so because we have
everywhere
the more no no because we're not because
we have to stay with one woman in in the
west it enables more men to have a woman
if if they had polygamy yeah the best
men would get the best wives
but uh
i mean
i mean i do i do i do think men are
biologically predispositioned to cheat
but i also think you can make choices to
not put yourself in those situations
yeah um so i i kind of i kind of
understand what both of you guys are
saying because i one hand i really do
think
a lot of guys if it's thrown at them are
gonna have a really hard time turning it
down and there's going to be a very like
like tiger woods i think of right he he
had that whole
he had like facebook groups full of
women right and then like that man was
wildin but but like most guys don't have
a a bus full of brazilian models waiting
for them at the end of a golf course i
think most men couldn't turn that down
but at the same time like my dad never
cheated on my mom right and he's in a
top half a percent of earners but he
just doesn't drink and doesn't put
himself in those situations
so
i don't think just because you're
biologically predisposed to to cheat
or to be
polygamous i don't
i don't think that means you need to act
on it what i would say as an example
is if
it's it's
men are biologically predispositioned to
violence far more than women okay
now if a man started to bat the [ __ ] out
of somebody in the street what's the
first thing we'd all say
why can't you control yourself yeah
right so i think you can also apply it
to this i think
this is going to piss a lot of men off
i'm sorry but the truth of the matter is
yes i will agree you are biologically
predispositioned to to have more than
one woman or seek out more than one
woman spread your seed so to call it
right
that doesn't mean you need to act on it
and i think as a man you can
truly be happy long term yeah without
acting on it i think you can i should
say
go ahead like it's men are more loyal to
their friends than they are they're
women sometimes
men men will not sleep with a friend if
if men
will say i'm not sleeping with a girl
that's been with their friend or that's
a friend's ex that's not loyal
but they'll sleep around behind the
woman they're supposed to love more than
anything back like no no the reason why
i don't sleep with my friends with the
girl that's been with my friend is
because i don't like i don't want
no i'm not saying the woman that's slept
around i'm saying if your friend was in
a relationship with a girl or
like someone your friend not even a
relationship say your friend had fancied
a girl who liked a girl and had told you
you probably wouldn't go there because
of your friend but what i'm saying to
you is you will go behind you will sleep
out of your marital beds but that's not
that's not because because men show
loyalty to women in different ways yep
and so so them is protection and
provisioning that's like that's how they
show loyalty okay and so you're put
you're protecting they're not protected
by sleep it's sleeping around that's not
very good no no no no
it's resources right there they're not
perfect for it's in protection so if
someone breaks into your house who's
expected to go go fight the robber or
whatever it is that's protection but if
with their friends like they don't get
their protection and provisioning yeah
you're judging us by the woman's
measuring stick yeah
i don't think that means men are more
loyal to their friends than their
partners we as men we provide a
different set of values for you so
though a man may cheat
the values that he is providing to you
again
it all goes back to
the way we are on a biological level
this isn't agreed upon by most people
from what i've seen yeah
but the science is very clear that we
are all
still like our brains are still ancient
that's just the truth of matter so if
you're gonna act out of impulse that's a
biological impulse and your brain the
decisions that you make the way you
think is actually still very primal so
for a man to look at another woman and
cheat now i'm not saying he has to do it
you can't argue a man for the impulse
for the lust
and i would even go as far as to say
acting on it however the values that he
provides you
are
physical security
now in modern day times
financial security
okay
and
ultimately he can go out and fend for
himself and get all of the resources
needed
i think ultimately women care more about
those traits those qualities that a man
can provide if he used to [ __ ] up and
accidentally sleep with a woman but he
can still provide all of those things
for you i think
and it i think it also does depend on
age right so if you're younger you're
far more likely to go i've got no real
investment in this man fine i can move
on but i've i can see many situations in
my life and we probably all can where
the man
so she's invested in a man such that
she's now got a house on a mortgage
she's now got many many kids
they are married one slip up i think if
women are deep down honest with
themselves they'll admit that that one
slip up i don't think it does anything
i don't think i don't think it means he
loves me any less there's nothing
i'm saying having a whole other
relationship that's detrimental okay but
that's that's different yeah that is
that is different
a relationship is very different yeah
honestly the older generation still got
through that they did yeah they did i
know so many grandparents that had like
side chicks for a hot minute and i don't
i don't agree with it
but i think they were just kind of built
of a different cloth right
would you would you accept you would i
accept cheating i always say if i had
kids it's not about me anymore
because once you have kids you put the
kids first so if i had kids no i i if i
had kids i would accept it if i
didn't have kids now i'm leaving
as many of you know i was just banned on
tick-tock and we are demonetized on a
daily basis on this platform
if you want to help please consider
sending a super thanks below every
donation helps and it helps make what we
do possible